i-42 on your thursday morning it is
earth day
always a great time to think about how
we can all work to reduce our impact on
the environment and joining us live via
zoom this morning it's our old friend
electronics technology expert it's dr
frank vigiano
some energy-saving tech products for us
today good morning dr frank
hey good morning so great to be with you
thank you so i guess we're starting in
the kitchen with some kind of magic
refrigerator what's this all about
right right well you guys may know that
when i visit las vegas i'm the judge for
the consumer electronics innovation
awards
and this first product by lg this is
their this is their
refrigerator you see she knocked on the
door which is just amazing
so it's called the insta-view
door-in-door refrigerator with craft
knives what's really great about this
is it has this pulling now look at this
nate the coating comes down to the front
of the door
and it goes down into the crisper where
the vegetables are
and basically will allow your vegetables
to be pressured for two times longer
which is amazing
it also has fresh air filters which
circulate sports there
and the dead areas which is really
amazing and look at this it's got craft
ice which is amazing so
it does crush dice it does square ice
and lg exclusive to the wrong ones
which do not melt as quick and what's
also cool is they have filtered water
and you can determine the houses it goes
basically
from you know from basically four ounces
all the way to third or two
and it's got filtration and look at that
the doors open
now it's alerting her that the door's
open and then she goes and closes the
door
really energy efficient really safe and
one thing that's really cool too
is look for this this is the energy star
rating anybody that's buying appliances
you want to look for that
because that certifies that the product
is energy efficient
wow very fascinating okay so i
understand there's also something weird
or new about a vacuum cleaner that's
obviously got something else going on
with it what that's what's that all
about
yeah well this is great you remember the
old push lawn mowers we just
just pushed them sure no motor
whatsoever yeah so this is by karcher
it's their s4 twin sweeper which is
really cool and the video will basically
show this now
it's human power no electricity no
emissions
it cleans up five times quicker than a
conventional broom
it's easy to push very minimal effort
and it sweeps up to twenty six
thousand square feet per hour and
there's a twenty liter which is a five
and a quarter gallon onboard waste
container which you just saw
and it allows you to empty it your hands
do not get dirty it's got dual brushes
it's made by karcher
they're german engineering from germany
they're one of the best companies i've
been testing over the years
and currently available at cartridge.com
and amazon
and karcher.com it's on sale for 149.99
very inexpensive for something with no
engine yeah um
i think my wife would have wanted our
son to use that on the back patio
yesterday
but it didn't work out that way we're
gonna have to look at that one okay
something about a water leak system
what's next here dr frank
right this is this is called peril
protect and this is interesting because
a lot of people don't know
that the average you know her beverage
person
every day has about ten thousand dollar
leak repair going on in their home
so seven thousand homes in the us are
impacted daily by water damage
a lot of people don't know that so
basically what you do is you take these
sensors you place them
in the various areas where you have
appliances that use water
and it provides you know basically it
will detect that it'll it'll provide 24
7 support
it'll even dispatch a vetted contractor
if you wish which is great
and what i love about it is it's
installs in minutes you simply unbox it
activate the hub
put the sensors where you need to starts
at 19
a month by payrollprotect.com and it
saves water
and saves headaches and also insurance
claims
wow we got a couple more to look at and
then we'll make sure folks know how to
contact you to learn more about these
uh something about the we know there's a
lot of electric cars on the road
one of the big concerns people have dr
frank is what if i can't find a charging
station
exactly you know that's called battery
anxiety nate
and one of the things that this is by
itself there's a portable electric
vehicle charger
and basically the benefit of this is of
course and this company their favorite
company busily
have innovative energy saving products
and this particular one as you can
imagine
is for ev for electric vehicles it'll
work with any car
doesn't matter you put it in your trunk
you take it with you and you can charge
it anywhere you can find the outlet
charges six times faster than level one
charger which is great
but it's easy to use cost effective
perfect for any cars whether it's tesla
4
gm it doesn't really matter comes with a
24 foot cable
429 you can find it at itself.com
and you can find it at costco and amazon
as well but what i love about it
you don't have to worry about not being
able to charge it exactly okay we have
time for one more real quick
speaking of cars uh some special new
tires
yes continental by the way it's their
150th anniversary
and we'll simply have got some slides to
show you but what's interesting
about continental is they've been
involved in energy saving for years
and what's interesting about the product
they basically did the first world's
first automobile tire
and pattern tread and now they have
smart covers so you can see so they went
from natural rubber to synthetic rubber
and now they're making rough tires out
of
dandelions can you imagine that but the
eco plus technology improves trend wire
it allows the tire to run with less
resistance and the slide that's on the
screen i want to point that out because
it's very important
continental is the only one that does
this but inside the trend there are
indicators
there's a d of w mass with dry wet and
stuff and those indicators when they
fade away
after the tire is being worn it tells
you it's not safe to drive in stone
anymore
not safe to drive and when it's wet and
if the d shows up you better get it in
pair of tires
all right hey we uh how do we find out
more from you dr frank is there a
website for you
yes what's new drink.com or
whatsnew.comc.com
and all the information will be on there
and that will help our
to help our viewers basically save money
and look at products that are basically
going to be affordable as well
always a pleasure talking with you dr
frank uh next time we have to do this in
person the zoom's
great but we have no audio issue with
you but thank you so much
always a pleasure dr frank nate i can't
wait to come to the studio to see
everybody we'll have a great time
as we always do